ibm security's cost of a data breach
report has returned we're going to look
at key stats takeaways and
recommendations all on this episode of
ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news announcements about ibm
technology
the cost of a data breach report
provides insights and recommendations to
it risk management and security leaders
on factors that can either increase or
help mitigate the rising cost of data
breaches
the research studied 550 real breaches
that occurred between march 2021 and
march 2022
terrifyingly they found that 83 of
organizations they studied experience
more than one data breach and reaching
an all-time high the cost of a data
breach averaged 4.35 million dollars in
2022
the report provides a view on how dozens
of factors impacted the costs that keep
adding up after a data breach occurs it
examines root causes short-term and
long-term consequences of data breaches
and the mitigating factors and
technologies that allowed companies to
limit losses
now the cost of a data breach report is
packed full of an incredible amount of
information and if i were to try to
cover it all we'd be here for hours
we're all busy people and three minutes
of me is more than enough in your day so
i'm just gonna cover a few of the main
points
make sure you check out the full report
which i've got linked below and up here
the research found that on average it
takes 277 days to identify and contain a
breach
but when you can contain it in under 200
days the cost of a data breach go down
by a million dollars
so how can you identify and contain a
breach faster
well organizations using security ai and
automation detected and contained
incidents 74 days faster on average
additionally organizations with extended
detection and response technologies
identified and contained breaches 29
days faster
all in all the average breach cost
savings associated with an incident
response team and regularly tested ir
plan was 2.66 million dollars that's a
lot of cash you can save with some
planning and preparation
luckily for all of us ibm security
provides some recommendations and steps
and organizations can take to help
reduce the financial cost and
reputational consequences of a data
breach
first design a zero trust architecture
reassess all relationships within the
business environment and re-architect
the network based on zero trust
principles
second use extended detection and
response tools as i mentioned earlier
this will help identify and contain
breaches faster
third create and test incident response
playbooks these are two of the most
effective ways to mitigate the cost of a
potential data breach
fourth conduct adversary simulations to
get your teams in practice
fifth leverage soar technologies to
accelerate incident response via
automation
and sixth adopt open hybrid cloud
capabilities to help your team become
more efficient and collaborative
i've only just scratched the surface on
all the useful information the cost of a
data breach report provides so please
make sure you download the full report
from the link i've got in the
description of this video
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered please make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now